a
[Música]
opção 1
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muitas coisas passaram pela minha cabeça
quando eu soube que estaria neste palco
falando com vocês um pouco do que se
passa na cabeça de uma cientista mas o
que isso uma cientista empreendedora eu
sempre fui uma pessoa muito curiosa não
somente com aquela curiosidade
investigativa nos porque mas quando a
cidade experimental de querer colocar a
mão na massa e um antes de observação
uma das primeiras observações que eu fiz
foi justamente a meu respeito eu
escrevei estudar direito não faria de
mim uma pessoa com brilho nos olhos que
eu achava que faria talvez por eu estar
fazendo aquilo apenas por ser uma
profissão ou mais tradicional isso
aconteceu quando eu fui apresentada a
ciência no finalzinho do Ensino
Fundamental eu vi que aquela disciplina
poderia me dar respostas e respostas
para perguntas o mesmo poderia formular
então eu comecei a me encantar pela
ciência e esse Encanto pela ciência ele
na verdade veio com o mesmo
questionamento do momento em que eu
percebi que talvez criar soluções e o
meu lugar no laboratório eram coisas que
estavam um pouquinho fora de sintonia
naquele momento bom 2008 quando eu
concluí o curso técnico em química e
participar o curso bacharel em química
eu tinha certeza que só está dentro de
um laboratório isso já Faria de mim uma
cientista levem Grand isso não aconteceu
eu comecei a me sentir como uma estranha
dentro do meu ambiente de trabalho eu já
trabalhava em laboratórios indústria na
época e isso aconteceu quando eu
literalmente parava e observava pela
janela e observava as pessoas os bairros
é conservado como sociedade e a partir
daí eu não entendi que existem tantos
problemas e tão poucas ou tão complexas
soluções que me senti uma estranha
naquele local não era pelo que eu estava
fazendo mas justamente pelo porque eu
estava fazendo
então eu preciso aqui fazer um paralelo
o que acontece na vida de um cientista é
que muitas vezes a gente precisa
realmente pesquisar faz uma pesquisa
para uma tese para o trabalho e o
percurso que pode levar meses ou até
mesmo anos e no meio desse percurso Às
vezes a gente encontra um assunto que
chama muito a nossa atenção e a gente
quer e afunda até porque a gente quer
ver isso aqui no falando sentido só que
se as contas vezes não está muito
relacionada essa tese principal então a
gente veio que guardo numa caixinha para
ver a pesquisar depois e o que acontece
com esse ver depois de pesquisar depois
é muito porque alguns recursos que falta
para o cientista é o recurso de nascer
então a gente se apega muito aquela
pesquisa que está sendo financiada ou
aquela pesquisa de trabalho para dar
continuidade e realmente deixa esse
assunto interessante no modo de espera o
que acontece é que eu não quis esperar
eu não quis esperar a partir do momento
que eu percebi a partir de pesquisas que
os metais pesados além de muitos riscos
à saúde eles chegavam a nós de muitas
formas na área de cosméticos que me
chamou muita atenção na contaminação do
solo e eu que realmente me deixou
preocupada e muito esticada na
alimentação
E desde que eu notei a quantidade de
metais pesados nas frutas verduras e
legumes eu quis pesquisar isso muito a
fundo eu já trabalhava em laboratórios e
por isso eu consegui fazer um teste o
outro fazer uma pesquisa outro nem
precisa laboratórios que eu trabalhava e
isso obviamente não aconteceu com o
tempo com a velocidade que eu precisava
Para ter embasamento porque quando a
gente acha que está descobrindo algo que
a gente precisa de embasamento para
poder levar isso para as pessoas com
mais assertividade levar esses academia
com pesquisa ou até mesmo para o mercado
e esse percurso durou mais ou menos
quatro anos porque eu realmente estava
na faculdade e por trabalhar durante o
período universitário um curso que é
para ser Matutina para o reino de Uno eu
não tive como aplicar essa pesquisa para
o meu trabalho de conclusão final e nem
para algum processo de iniciação
científica
E mais uma vez eu guardei essa decisão
bolso
porém sempre atenta aos pestes e as
pesquisas que estavam fazendo enjoando
paralelo para ter certeza que isso
poderia no futuro Lhe garante uma
pesquisa maior fazendo aqui então uma
proximidade entre a vida de um cientista
e a vida de empreendedor o que acontece
aqui às vezes a gente precisa encontrar
um MVP que a mínimo produto viável para
cada solução e eu encontrei esse mínimo
produto viável eu cheguei uma solução
líquida que removia até 65 por cento dos
metais pesados e agroquímicos das frutas
verduras legumes e a partir disso a
partir desse experimento A partir dessa
solução eu fiquei no Lago vida eu levo
isso novamente para academia e tem
alguma outra pesquisa alguma e deixar
isso no meio acadêmico
ou para o mercado e bem para algumas
pesquisas que fiz eu descobri a Fatec
Sebrae que fica em São Paulo e decidi
arriscar eu decidi me colocar novamente
nesse lugar dele sentiu uma estranha
seria uma cientista
aprendendo a empreender uma cientista no
mundo completamente diferente de tudo
que já tinha passado até ali até porque
eu empreendedorismo justamente isso E
desde que eu entrei na Fatec com o
objetivo de melhorar a alimentação das
pessoas com todas as dúvidas e todas as
certezas que não tinha até ali eu decidi
em 2017 Hyundai sacado em química e é
claro que isso não aconteceu sem muita
ajuda do corpo acadêmico isso não
aconteceu sem o conhecimento E aí e todo
mundo precisava para ter uma noção de
mercado porque não adianta ter um
produto na bancada e não levaram no
mercado não levar essa solução para a
sociedade que é onde a gente realmente
precisa então quando a gente pensa na
alimentação pois a gente pensa na
alimentação saudável o nosso Imaginário
não da nossa cabeça com imagens de
frutas legumes bebê perguntava praticar
exercícios larguras essas imagens elas
são muito coloridas elas são muito
bonitas ela tem muito brilho mas quando
a gente se dá conta da quantidade de
toxinas que eles fizeram eles podem ter
essa imagem aí fica um pouco mais opaca
isso perde um pouco do brilho e isso é
uma coisa que não pode acontecer bom a
loura estima que até 2050 nós sejamos
uma população de aproximadamente
9,3 bilhões de pessoas a
essa demanda a gente precisa de uma
produção agrícola mais ou menos você tem
o conceito maior do que temos hoje desde
Setembro
140/200 Paulo Brasil e isso com certeza
vai ligar na utilização de fertilizantes
e agroquímicos e mais acesso os
agroquímicos eles são substâncias que
tem um objetivo a eliminação de pragas
na agricultura
só que essas substâncias eram são
tóxicas e causam e fiz o nosso organismo
a curto médio e longo prazo dependendo é
claro do tempo de exposição e da Fórmula
daquele produto
diverso eles são os responsáveis por
levar os metais pesados para esses
alimentos através de solo contaminado e
através da ingestão os fertilizantes no
primeiro momento eles podem aparecer ao
longo porque eles têm como finalidade de
e o solo o que ele tem de deficiência de
alguns nutrientes e assim melhorando a
produção agrícola o que acontece é
novamente a má utilização e o excesso da
utilização desse produto faz com que
alguns metais cheio a nosso nosso
organismo alguns deles são tóxicos como
chumbo cádmio Arsênio e Mercúrio
o que tem para amenizar um pouco essa
situação são os limites toleráveis de
ingestão desses metais mas esses metais
eles têm um processo chamado de
bioacumulação essa meu algumas que é o
significa o quê mesmo dentro desses
limites toleráveis eles conseguem se
acumulando seja no solo ou seja do
organismo então a médio e longo prazo
eles estão bem conseguem causar
malefícios
a solução criada pela descartado química
atua justamente dentro desse processo da
bioacumulação
minimizando e reduzindo os metais
pesados nos alimentos antes da sua
ingestão isso faz com que eles Xerém com
o limite menor no organismo ir mesmo
depois da utilização da solução quando a
gente termina despurificar movimento é
claro que o rese vai voltar para o meio
ambiente só que ele tava pesado ele já
passou por um processo químico chamado
de que elas são que explicam a grosso
modo é como se esse mental fosse
encapsulado com uma bolha e Então nesse
processo ele não é capaz de transmitir
os mesmos malefícios que ele transmite
ia antes de passar por essa Purificação
Essa é a solução que a despertar com
química e é muito para Além disso e nós
não queremos e não podemos adrenalina É
de uma alimentação saudável e uma
alimentação de qualidade ao fato dela
muito provavelmente não ser um saudável
assim nós temos que garantir a segurança
na alimentação para nossa população o
objetivo desse projeto ele não é um
produto se não é estar com alguém se não
é retirar ele faz utilizados nos
alimentos somente mas ela também
levantaram esses debates e falar sobre a
desigualdade na alimentação
e o acesso a uma alimentação de
qualidade ainda é um privilégio de uma
minoria isso não pode ser um sonho de
forma alguma isso sempre leves causar
estranheza isso deve-se usar os
confortos porque é desconfortável esse
as desigualdades não salvaram estranheza
Os Estranhos seremos nós muito obrigado
a
E aí